on this single block is 100 minecraft
players i'm about to let them build and
whoever is the last man standing gets an
ultimate youtuber set up comprised of
all these items here server give the
blocks oh i got blocked trying to get a
few quick knocks when we start build
children built only one person is
building and they're all following yeah
oh he died
hey jimmy i found chandler
no they're still respawning i know i can
kill people and not feel bad about it
i know i just killed this guy but don't
worry currently anyone who dies responds
but we're gonna end that starting now if
they die don't respawn them server i was
about to kill carl oh no they're
building up let's get some land of our
own i think we need our own little area
of land oh wait where are you where am i
i don't know it's been less than a
minute and they went from one block to
this and you guys know the deal carl and
chandler are in a different discord call
competing like normal well look how much
of a civilization we've already built
together look at this they started at
one block there's a lot of people on
this giant block here and then there's
just wine why also there's been some
savage people they'll just run up to
people and destroy the block underneath
them oh you mean like this
just kidding kidding kitty
get him get him oh i almost got him
hey we got the bait and trap wait mrs
carl jacobs
chris chris chris yeah i have a
challenge for you what's up can you go
this entire video without killing
someone starter timer let's see how long
you can go without killing someone oh
look at carl he's begging for it man
one less to worry about huh what is up
contestant the prize for this
competition is an ultimate youtuber
setup you get a beefy pc you get three
monitors actually we'll make it five
monitors mouse keyboard camera tripod
everything and anything you need setups
for the boys i'm like mr b because i am
mr beast good luck and whoever wins gets
a set up wait this guy's literally
creative look at this island of people
over here whoa what is going on over
there all right so this guy's got the
strat he just sits in this little thing
i think this guy kind of has a strat
right now mr morgan chris look i'm on
both sides of my screen right now and
you look at yourself you're like other
jimmy what do you think about that
should i kill tom cobbler no you
shouldn't kill him that's why they hate
chris okay i won't kill him i now have
an inner monologue let's get him hey
what's up newbie doobie what up noob
nothing
uh
carl and chandler just came up and
killed him while i was talking to him oh
newbie no
go sorry doobie they're going around
bullying the people we're trying to
interview they don't want us to get good
content the only logical thing to do is
to neutralize the threat to the content
but you're not allowed to kill people
what if i do this though this isn't me
killing
time out since you keep killing people
you have to sit on the toilet for how
long until the video's over no oh hey
chris i didn't see you there hey it's me
chris while i was putting chris and
timeout you guys did a lot with the
colored blocks meanwhile we gotta talk
about this toilet paper wall it's like
translucent i don't know what to do i'm
all alone
[Music]
all right so carl if this person's
actually dream they'll be able to
survive this
oh dreams in our video non-clickbait
here let me let me add them to the call
to test it what up dream hey dream hello
how are you still like best friends with
george and stuff nah live action drama
right here right now you're already a
youtuber so you don't need a youtuber
set up so we can just give it to whoever
else if you win no no no
what are toilets made out of we just
gave them different color wool but it
means nothing carl i think it's time we
spice things up
p
b p enabled oh look at chandler now that
pvp is on there i'll get a darker
chandler blue team let's go
whoa whoa
whoa
oh no oh no no no one told me
65 people remain 65 and 64 of them
aren't getting an ultimate youtuber set
up welcome back chandler well hello carl
we need to spice things up
i want mayhem i want chaos they want to
take our tnt go down with the tnt oh my
god look at my character look at me oh
my
there's still 52 players remaining which
is 51 more than i want server start
shrinking the circle carl watch this
when i right click
the circle shrinks i have all the power
bring me my phone i'm remoting into this
computer and now i'm gonna ban my
account on his computer wait who are you
just laying tnt everywhere i don't know
why you're looking at my screen right
now carl can you stop playing tnt of
course good because i wanted to
this started out as one block and look
at it oh god this entire tribe is going
down oh dreams in it two dreams are in
it van
chris
shrinking the circle by 12 wait what
happened i got banned wow
what did i get banned yeah
i banned you from the toilet baby
what the heck
yeah
i'm at my computer now remind me next
time i put chris on the toilet to take
his phone can i get off the toilet now
you can stay on the toilet forever now
it looks like a map
it is crazy to think about that this
used to be one block anyways as i was
saying boom boom boom should i stop no
two more wait did you mean two anymore
20 seems kind of crazy but five doesn't
we're down to 35 players i'm rooting for
the second place person right now if
five people do not die in the next
minute i will get angry don't please
stop guys hurry kill each other there is
currently 35 people alive the minute has
started oh please don't get jimmy angry
guys oh carl's best killed monarch
knights oh
oh guys yo carla's best is insane two
people have to die in the next 10
seconds so i'll get mad
stop no no guys stop hurry three two
one somebody died
five people did not die no
you know what happens when i'm angry no
i don't but
holy cow you thought that was it no
there's more i'm doing an airstrike
i didn't want to resort to this but all
you had to do was kill some people yo
good jimmy jimmy that's half the map i
don't care they should have killed some
people what now they don't have much
land to walk on well good let's shrink
the circle some more oh
it's shrinking it's shrinking i just
clicked it 30 times i don't even care
i'm doing one more airstrike jimmy stop
being so angry no
oh oh somebody fell i would jump off too
if i was you
oh somebody fell i'm still slightly mad
we're gonna shrink it more
are you okay man
i am no longer angry jimmy now i'm happy
again this is a fun video are we having
fun carl yeah man yeah we're all having
fun sounds like they're having a lot of
fun in there i wish i had friends if ten
people do not die in the next three
minutes i swear on my mama no not his
mama it will get back no
there's 30 players remaining holy cow oh
someone's fighting oh
29 oh double team over here oh my gosh
oh my that bodied what is going on here
carl tp to me okay i'm right here are
they teaming wait here wait wait oh my
gosh i accidentally dropped something
can you help me pick it up oh i think
it's too late oh yeah yeah you dropped
some tnt oh
poor guy
we have 50 seconds for seven people to
die let's start fighting do it
oh carl that's evil that way they don't
see it coming that's something chris
would do
yo yo stop time's up with seven seconds
remaining ten people actually died
thanks guys i don't have all day players
forgive me for what i'm about to do oh
no
holy cow very small now this one person
carla's best is literally alone right
now what i don't understand is why
aren't they fighting only one of them is
winning fight each other they're being
dimwits entertain me fight oh we got
some fighting they're all in the mix
fighting right now holy
oh oh coral is literally on the floor oh
that might be a mlg strat right here
wait carl's best is on the border so
what happens if i do this
oh my gosh they literally built in at
the perfect timing i don't know what's
about to happen but forgive me lord
all right wish of luck where's the vlog
everybody
oh carpet bump holy cow how many people
just died wait a minute like six guys
you gotta be on your toes we got one
underneath and no one knows carl yeah i
need you to tnt while i shrink the
border okay go how
shrinking tnt is falling what would they
do pal why don't they just survive it's
not that hard just don't die let's add
some of them to the call
what up everybody left hello hey man
hello hi we just gave all of you armor
and the diamond sword last standing gets
that ultimate youtuber set up paul
talk great i love you man i love you too
if you guys don't start killing each
other i'm gonna keep shrinking the
circle oh i can name one person that
wouldn't like you to keep oh wait the
guy in the box fell oh all right now
seven or eight why are you guys running
around each other start fighting here
i'm gonna cause some man tnt going down
have fun everybody
oh someone fell
oh my gosh dream died dream's dead it's
a 1v1 1v1 all right it's a 1v1 coral is
best all right this is that no girls
[ __ ] just fell no
let's go
chris you can get off the toilet yay
you just want an epic pc five monitors a
keyboard a mouse a microphone and
whatever else we throw in the package
what's your final word oh my god it
should help me with my universe to work
well now you can drop out of school and
be a youtuber
i don't think i'm a queen thank you for
watching hit the subscribe button see
you later